and the red sox will run into bryce
wilson who was a winner last time out as
he beat up on the miami marlins jackie
bradley jr will lead off on the final
sunday of regular season play bradley a
pending free agent failed in deep back
toward the wall it goes duvall reaches
up he can't get any lunch for it didn't
get it jackie in the second with a
double and jackie took a big turn but
retreats that was an awkward lunch for
that ball by adam duvall in left field
as it went over his head look for a
moment like he almost overran it a
little bit took a strange angle so put a
runner in scoring position now for
rafael devers here's the pitch on its
way line to right field deep it's going
to hit off the wall
jackie will score
rafi devers with a line shot off the
wall in right field rbi number 43 for
devers and the red sox lead to one
nothing
swing and he missed bogarts is down on
strikes there's the first out of the
game for wilson two on with two out ball
rolled up to his hip buddy recovered to
make the play and that retires the side
28 pitches for bryce wilson boston
touches him for the game's first run and
they will face a familiar face in nick
pavetta the former philly now starting
for the red sox so here is freddie good
series head to head with the red sox
this year seven out of 15 with a homer
freeman swings it's a shot nice pick on
a short hop at second base boy nicely
done by arus
that ball you either catch it or it
picks you he picked it so ozuna he's had
a remarkable year he's fighting for the
rbi and home run title he's also got a
shot at the hits lead in the national
league swing and a drive deep left field
marcelo zuna has taken over the national
league homer lead with a mammoth first
inning shot yeah fastball middle middle
and marcel is not going to miss many of
those his fifth homer against the red
sox is 18th of the year and that ties
the game first and third for boston and
jackie bradley's coming up
freeman is coming home and a perfect
strike no chance for lynn who doesn't
bother to slide
he's gunned down by freddie that's the
second out good play by freddie good job
by tyler give him a little bit of room
but then the moment he gets the ball
blocking the plate and getting easy out
right into the shift dansby will make
the flip to first in time
and that takes care of debra's and the
red sox nice play by freddie freeman to
preserve a tie another cool stat on
dansby he has not hit into a double play
all year it's the swanson and he swings
and misses it a slider away spotted
beautifully over the outside edge
pavetta's pitch good fast ball over the
inside edge and flowers knew it back to
back hayes
all the red sox have two on with two out
runners go and the pitch grounded to the
right side long run ozzy he's gonna
glove he's gonna throw to first it's
gonna be in time by a quarter step
what a play by ozzy albee's that's the
only chance he had and chavis been safe
they would have gotten a run instead
oziobiz with his great range puts out a
third inning boston fire nothing in one
on ozzie albie's popped up into center
field i say popped up it's hit very well
back on it bradley at the wall he leaps
and makes the catch crashing into the
400 marker vintage jackie bradley in
what may well be his final game with the
red sox i don't know that he robbed a
home run but absolutely a ball that
would have gone off the top of the wall
there's jackie who has doubled scored a
run bradley drives one deep to right
field this is into the gap does it have
enough it is gone
jackie bradley jr hits one out himself
to right center field and it is two one
red side sander bogarts is the batter
pitch is hitting the air to left field
pretty deep back it goes by the wall and
this ball is gone he's homered xander
bogarts with a home run his 11th of the
year is 28th rbi and he's hitting 300.
freeman will come up with a chance to
turn the game around with one swing
swaying and a fly ball hit toward right
that is going to be caught by lynn and
twice today freddie has made an out on
the first pitch once in the first inning
and here in the fifth here's the pitch
and ozuna swings and loops one on a soft
line cuts one of roos catches for the
out that retires the side and the bases
are loaded flowers will be the hitter
one two is strike three called he got
him on the outside corner perfect pitch
on the outside for darwin and now it's
up to ender and ciarte if the braves are
to score in the sixth inning
swing and a miss and he struck him out
and celebrated screams with delight his
last pitch throne of 2020 now it's chris
martin's turn to get an inning in he's
had 18 spectacular ones for the braves
so far this season
uh-oh
uh-oh did martin hurt himself
here comes george poulos 2-1 pitch to
devers appears to have hurt himself and
he's bent to the waist i thought i saw
chris point to the upper part of his
right leg you can see after he threw the
pitch he immediately called for the
training staff to come out he's walking
off under his own power but
any time a pitcher calls for the trainer
something's gone or in a big way one on
one out for jd martinez
got him high fly to right field turning
around marcakus and that's out of here a
rare blast for martinez
and the red sox lead it five to one
that's on the ground pablo it hits the
third base bag and skips by oh terrible
luck one runs gonna score
chavis on his way to second it's a six
to one game nothing you can do on that
nope
smoked into right field a base hit one
run scores chavis around third he's
getting the green light and the red sox
are putting a hurting on luke jackson
it's a five run inning marcakis has
grounded out one three
there's a shot hit toward the gap in
right center look at nick marchakis
guess what he's gonna have they just had
to add one more double yep why not good
to see nick with a two-hit game as the
playoffs are about to start that double
ties him with edgar martinez for 54th on
the all-time list
back to right field and that ball gets
out of here first big league dinger
jonathan aruz with his first career home
run touches them all in atlanta